وسط استمرار التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه وعقب اقتحامها الليله الماضيه
مدينه رام الله انسحبت قوت الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من المدينه بعد مداهمتها
لبنايه سكنيه في حي المصايف وافد مراسل
الجزيره بان قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت شقه
سكنيه في البنايه وفتشتها وعبثت
بمحتوياتها وحاصرت بنايات سكنيه بالقرب من
هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون الفلسطيني في
المدينه واقتحمت قوات الاحتلال ايضا مدينه
يطا جنوبيه محافظه الخليل بالضفه الغربيه
وكانت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد اقتحمت
مدينه الظهريه وقريه دير العسل جنوب
الخليل كما اقتحمت قريتي حوسان ونحالين
غرب بيت لحم واندلعت مواجهات بين قوات
الاحتلال وشبان
فلسطينيين هذا وقد انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
من مخيم الفوار جنوبي الخليل بعد اقتحام
مناطق في المحافظه وقد دارت مواجهات بين
جنود الاحتلال وشبان فلسطينيين ما اسفر عن
اصابه خمسه فلسطينيين كما اعتقلت قوت
الاحتلال ثمانيه شبان ودهمت منازل
المواطنين وفتشتها واجبرت النساء والاطفال
على المبيت في
العراء معنا الان من رام الله مراسل
الجزيره محمد خيري محمد ماذا بعد الانسحاب
من رام الله لقوات الاحتلال بالاضافه لما
شهدته مناطق مختلفه في الضفه الغربيه خلال
الليل وساعه الصباح
ايضا بالفعل بات مشهدا معتادا في كل ليله
في الضفه الغربيه منذ السابع من اكتوبر
وحتى هذا اليوم مشاهد الاقتحامات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه للمدن والمخيمات والقرى في
الضفه الغربيه من جنوبها ووسطها وحتى
شمالها فالى جانب ما يجري في هذه اللحظات
في مدينه جنين من اشتباكات عنيفه واقتحام
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شهدت ايضا
مدينه رام الله هذا المساء المساء الليله
الماضيه عمليه اقتحام من قبل جنود جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من عده محاور وحاصروا
بنايه في حي المصايف ثم اقتحموا شقه سكنيه
كنا هناك ونقلنا في بث حي ومباشر الدمار
الذي حل في هذه الشقه والتخريب الذي اح
حثه الجنود الاسرائيليون داخلها ثم
اقتحموا شقه مقابله لها وهناك ايضا
انتشروا فيها ونشروا قواتهم على اسطح
البنايه ثم انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من المكان وكذلك اقتحمت مدينه
نابلس من قبل اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه
انتشرت الاليات في عدد من الشوارع وخاصه
في منطقه الضاحيه شرقي مدينه نابلس وداهمت
عددا من منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الى جانب ذلك ايضا شهدت مدينه
قلقيليه وخاصه بلده عزون عمليه اقتحام
واسعه من قبل جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الذي اعتدى على عدد من الشبان الفلسطينيين
وانتشرت قواته في عدد من الاحياء وكذلك
مدن جنوبي الضفه الغربيه وخاصه مدينه
الخليل
ويطا ومخيم الفوار على وجه الخصوص شهدتا
عمليه اقتحام واسعه من محاور عده من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي نشر قواته في عدد
من الاحياء ودهم عدد من المنازل ونكل
واعتدى على عدد من الشبان الفلسطينيين في
مخيم الفوار دارت رحى المواجهات بين
الشبان الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما ادى الى اصابه عدد من
الشبان
بجروح بلغ عدد اجمالي عدد الاسرى الحالات
الاعتقال عفوا في الضفه الغربيه ومدينه
القدس المحتله منذ السابع من اكتوبر وحتى
هذا اليوم اكثر من
6250 ح اعتقال لا ولم تصدر حتى الان
بيانات رسميه حول معتقلي الليله الماضيه
من الضفه الغربيه شكرا جزيلا لك من رام
الله مراسل الجزيره محمد خيري